some people are drinking a little too
much during this period and I think it's
fair to ask you are you indulging a
little bit right now you have a hip
flask that I can't see I don't but I do
actually have a bottle of gin in my desk
Wow is that a bad sign
that's a the bat it's not that you have
it it's that you're hiding it Stephen
that's the real problem
you know and I've got something equally
cool and sexy which is I have this
little bobble head Abraham Lincoln
kitten Wow actually if you pop the top
it's rum that's a picture of my dad
right there when he was he was in the
army uh he was a captain this is these
are dog tags right there that's he was
also he was an immunologist at the at
the National Institutes of Health
actually he was associate director of
the NIH for allergy and infectious
disease he was basically Anthony pouchy
this is my father's father and his wife
my grandmother and yeah just blossoms
we're losing viewers
no you're shedding viewers like crazy
right now let me tell you story about
this desk let me tell you sorry about
this desk right here I can't wait
this desk belonged to lieutenant Stoney
back in the 1860s and it doesn't matter
what side he fought for it's a long time
ago let's not get bogged down in it okay
this is my this is my wife's family your
what happened Lee I'm not throwing
anybody under a bus here let me guess a
quick question did she call it the Civil
War or I bet she calls it the War of
Northern Aggression we just don't talk
about it Conan we don't are you starting
to think the way I'm thinking which is
yes I love my studio I love having an
audience but I'm telling you there are
people on the network level that are
watching these shows and saying hey wait
a minute that looks really good yeah why
do we need all that other stuff who
needs an Edie Sullivan Theater
when you've got the stony desk mm-hmm
and some books behind you
don't you think solve it The Ed Sullivan
Chipotle sounds pretty good little
revenue right there